do you worry that your fame
traps you
into the person
that you were before yeah well yeah
elvis became an elvis impersonator by
the time he died yeah do you fear that
you have become a jordan peterson
impersonator that do you fear of in some
part becoming
the famous suit wearing
brilliant jordan peter this the
certainty
in the pursuit of truth
always right i think i worry about it
more than anything else i hope
i hope i do i better has fame to some
degree when you look at yourself in the
mirror
and the quiet of your mind has it
corrupted you
no doubt in some regard i mean it's very
difficult thing to avoid you know
because
things change around you people are much
more likely to do
what you ask for example right and so
that's a danger because one of the
things that keeps you dying properly is
that people push back against you
optimally this is why so many
celebrities spiral out of control
especially the tyrannical types that say
run countries
everyone around them stops saying
yeah you're you're you're deviating a
little bit there they laugh at all their
jokes they open all their doors they
they always want something from them the
red carpet's always rolled out it's like
well you think would not be lovely it's
well
not if the red carpet is rolled out to
you while you're on your way to
perdition
that's not a good deal you just get
there more efficiently
and so one of the things that i've tried
to learn to manage is to get have people
around me all the time who are critics
who are saying yeah i could have done
that better and
you're a little too harsh there and
you're alienating people unnecessarily
there and you should have done some more
background work there and
and i think the responsibility attendant
upon that increases as your influence
increases and that's
that's a as your influence increases
then that becomes a lot of
responsibility
so you know and then maybe have an off
day and well one here's an example
i've been writing some columns lately
about things that perturb me
like the forthcoming famine
for example
and
it's hard to take those
um problems on
it's difficult to take those problems on
in a serious manner and it's frightening
and it would be easier just to go up to
the cottage with my wife and go out on
the lake and watch the sunset
and so i'm tempted to draw on
anger as a motivating energy
to help me overcome the
resistance to doing this but then that
makes me more harsh and judgmental in my
tone
when i'm reading such things for example
on youtube then might be optimal now
i've had debates about with people about
that because i have friends who say
no if you're calling out the
environmental
environmentalist globalists who are
harassing the dutch farmers
then
a little anger is just the ticket but
then others say well you know you don't
want to be too harsh because you
alienate people who would otherwise
listen to you it's like
that's a hard balance to get right but
also maybe anger
hardens your mind to where you don't
notice the the subtle quiet beauty of
the world
the quiet love that's always there that
permeates everything
sometimes you can become deeply cynical
about the world if
it's the nietzsche thing yeah battle not
with monsters unless ye become a monster
and if you gaze into the abyss the abyss
gazes also into you right but i would
say
bring it on
right because well i also say knowing
that he's absolutely right but
if you gaze into the abyss long enough
you see the light not the darkness
are you sure about that
i'm betting my life on it
yeah it's a heck of a bet well that's
because it might distort your mind to
where all you see
is it this is is abyss is the evil in
this world
i would say you haven't looked long
enough
you know that's back to the you're just
the limit the swords the flaming swords
it's like so i said the whole story of
christ was prefigured in that image
it's like the story of christ
psychologically
is
radical acceptance of the worst possible
tragedy that's what it means that's what
the crucifix means psychologically it's
like gaze upon that which you are most
afraid of but that story doesn't end
there because in in the in the story
christ goes through death into hell
so death isn't enough
the abyss the abyss of innocent death is
not sufficient to produce redemption
it has to be a voluntary journey to hell
and maybe that's true for everyone
and that's like there is no more
terrifying idea than that by definition
and so then well do you gaze upon that
well
who knows
who knows
you